jennifer devons to maclo only qualified
three months ago but soon she'll stop
work and start strike action joining
criminal barristers across england and
wales
over the past five years 25 of my
criminal legal bar have left the
profession 300 left last year so what
will happen if the government don't take
note of what we're saying is there will
soon be no barristers left who will
represent victims and defendants then
that is what is grinding the system to a
halt it's all about the fees paid for
legal aid work and barristers have been
taking action for over a month
escalating now with a vote for all-out
action
but the dispute goes back a decade
this chart shows how much barristers
earn the most experienced are on around
a hundred thousand pounds but those
starting out earn under 13 000 less than
the minimum wage
the criminal justice system is already
under strain with nearly 59 000
outstanding cases
and this backlog means on average
there's a 15-month wait from the time of
an offense to the completion of a trial
the victims commissioner says she's
writing to the justice secretary and
demanding an end to the dispute
that backlog is awful for victims now
people who've been traumatized by the
loss of a child in a car crash or been
raped or been stabbed their our lives
are on hold they're waiting for justice
they're waiting for
a finish to the thing and a lot of those
are going to drop out but just
prolonging it like this is awful and so
there's just they've just got to talk
it's got to be resolved
but time is running out for a resolution
the government says it's increased
criminal barristers fees by 15 percent
barristers argue it's not enough and
between both sides disagreement and
dispute and for victims and court rooms
yet more delay and disruption laura
bundock sky news